has the batman found a fresh approach to
some very familiar material or is it
flying around in the dark keep watching
to find out what the critics are saying
about this highly anticipated release
the various tv and movie adaptations of
batman over the past 80 years or so have
run the gamut from colorful and campy to
grim and violent the latest installment
of the franchise is director matt reeves
the batman in which robert pattinson
takes the reins as billionaire turned
vigilante bruce wayne it reportedly
follows him throughout his second year
of fighting crime in gotham city while
protecting the city he faces off against
paul danos riddler a serial killer who
begins targeting high-profile residents
and broadcasting his killing spree this
will be the notorious villain's first
appearance in a batman film since 1995's
batman forever in which jim carrey's
portrayal of the puzzle-obsessed
criminal earned critical praise after
facing production delays because of the
coven 19 pandemic the film is finally
slated for its theatrical release on
march 4th the batman also stars zoe
kravitz as catwoman jeffrey wright as
police lieutenant james gordon andy
circus as alfred pennyworth and colin
farrell as the penguin the first wave of
critical reaction to the film was
positive with many praising the gritty
return to form but as the release date
draws closer more nuanced takes are
coming out as of the making of this
video the batman has a 91 approval
rating on rotten tomatoes so it's
largely faring well with critics in a
review for strange harbors jeffrey zhang
praised the film's fresh direction given
just how much other superhero fare is
out there zhang wrote the batman is a
grand mosaic of interlocking pieces that
fit together as a refreshing antidote to
superhero fatigue he singled out kravitz
performance as the highlight
you got a lot of cats everything about
strength similarly in her review for
insider kirsten akuna said that there
isn't a weak link in the cast she also
dismissed concerns about the film's
nearly three hour run time and took a
big swing stating that robert pattinson
is the best live-action batman since
michael keaton now you want to get nuts
come on let's get nuts she added that
reeves and the crew quote had reverence
for batman's history on and off the
screen ign's alex stedman called the
batman a gripping gorgeous and at times
genuinely scary film and praised its
psychologically dark portrayal of bruce
wayne like the other critics she noted
how this film is totally unlike its
predecessors while still capturing the
heart of the source material for slash
film chris evangelista argued that this
might be the best batman movie to date
writing i know there will be plenty of
people who feel they are burned out on
all things batman that there couldn't
possibly be room for yet another
retelling of the same old tale but the
batman defies all the odds although the
batman has received plenty of praise
some critics were less than enthralled
by the long runtime and dark color
palette in his review for the san
francisco chronicle mick lasalle
concluded that as a whole the batman is
mostly just a collection of bad ideas he
praised zoe kravitz and paul dano's
performances but expressed confusion
about robert pattinson's performance
calling it stiff justice
the answer's justice lasalle also
questioned reeve's dystopian direction
calling it very 2019 as pre-pandemic as
skin-tight jeans he added reeves comes
up with a knock-off of joker only
without the wit and without the great
performance just a flimsy idea that
everything is awful corrupt and rotten
and he assumes that his concept is so
deep and profound that he needs three
hours to develop it for paste magazine
jacob allar called the film ambitious
and dedicated to its vision but said it
can't crack how to make the world's
greatest detective seem like one at all
aller says pattinson's batman is not
different enough to outrun his legacy's
ever-growing shadow polygon's joshua
rivera wrote that the film's biggest
issue is its inability to stand out
among the rest of the franchise he wrote
the batman is frustratingly safe a movie
full of potential for more and settling
for less it preaches to the choir
reinforcing the same ideas trodden over
and over again across five movies
multiple video games and every comic
book in the mold of frank miller and
david matsukelli's batman year one you
can decide for yourself when the batman
hits theaters march 4th 2022. check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the batman
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]